welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and as we look ahead at marvel's
what if the biggest reach into the
unknown is the marvel zombies scenario
rumored to be the fifth episode perhaps
later in the season but this series so
far has been super specific with the
subtle variant moments from the mcu that
led these alternate realities from peggy
carter responding differently to
erskine's requests just a throwaway line
we saw in the first cat film to episode
two where the ravagers abduct the wrong
earth kid for ego so what subtle mcu
moment that we all saw could have led to
a freaking zombie apocalypse how the
hell was the mcu at all close to
anything like that well in the infinity
saga re-watches i do weekly instead of
helping my fiance plan for our wedding i
realized the opening sequence of captain
america civil war totally centers around
a deadly infectious disease that very
nearly infects a massive population zone
in nigeria a mysterious biohazard which
we were never told exactly what it was
and when you re-watch those crucial
minutes not only do several possible
variance points present themselves but
you get a clearer picture of the very
real possibility of this disease
existing in the live-action mcu as well
hey by the way we have a new latest
obsession shirt inspired by what if
called cosmic witness it looks awesome
these are limited edition you gotta get
your hands on these because when you do
you'll get an added option to write in a
custom shout out that will appear on
screen in our what if after shows so go
check this out at newrockstarsmerch.com
okay the what if marvel zombies episode
is based on a five issue run of the
comics in 2005 and 2006 written by
walking dead creator robert kirkman the
show's producers have said that this
episode of what if draws more from its
comic source material than any other
episode of the series so it helps to go
back and look at what happened in those
comics that story is set in the
alternate dimension of earth 2149 but is
actually one that takes place really
across a couple different dimensions the
zombie virus is called the hunger and it
arrives from an unknown superhero from
another dimension and immediately
affects the avengers x-men fantastic
four all known superheroes turning them
into flesh-craving zombies but leaving
their intellect intact so that they're
still capable of communicating and more
terrifyingly tricking their prey so reed
richards from the ultimates dimension
earth 1610 at the time the more focal
home realm of the marvel stories gets
lured into the zombie dimension by an
older zombie reed richards the story is
great it ends up pivoting around magneto
the acolytes black panther and
eventually silver stripper and galactus
it's an amazing read highly recommend
but despite the claims that this episode
will draw more from these comics than
any other episode which i'm sure is true
i'm not sure it's gonna be a 100 direct
adaptation the australian footage shows
a few zombified versions of the avengers
including captain america and iron man
with their motor skills still
functioning just fine but cap at least
looks super rotten in the face classic
zombie monstrous i'm just not sure how
much intellect is left up there but more
importantly this moment at least seems
to follow bucky barnes as a point of
view character and i doubt marvel
studios would use this story to
introduce to the mcu characters like the
fantastic four magneto silver surfer
galactus i think they're more likely to
stay with alt versions of the mcu
characters we already know rather than
elicit wild expectations about the
depictions or voice actors behind these
long-awaited character reboots so that
brings us back to civil war a film that
i would argue is as much bucky barn
story as it is steve rogers or tony
starks and i think there's a good chance
the what if episode could hinge on that
lagos mission and instead show it going
terribly wrong now i know the correct
pronunciation is more like lagos but
they pronounce it lagos multiple times
in the movies so who am i to correct the
sacred mcu okay if you remember brock
rumlow crossbones led a group of
mercenaries to the institute for
infectious diseases in lagos where they
steal from the cold storage of bile
marked biohazard now infectious disease
centers like this in the cdc in atlanta
will keep in storage samples of past
contained diseases like smallpox ebola
so that they can continue to study them
and for future vaccine research rumlow
gasses this institute he breaks into
storage swipes the vial and passes it
off to one of his guides to throw off
the avengers they ditch their gear it's
a shell game now one of them has the
payload this leads to a momentary panic
by the avengers to track down which
shell contains the prize which kind of
feels like an interesting variable
moment right sam wilson takes down one
guy whose bag turns up empty but that
could be variance point option a sam on
that takedown could have broken the vial
infecting himself and making patient
zero literally airborne but option b
rumlow could have given it to the same
guy he did in the movie but sam still
figuring out how to operate his new red
wing drone could have missed and sniped
the vial instead oh but listen to me my
speculation is being kind of hard on sam
assuming he's a clumsy dude i don't
think that's fair so what about option c
natasha could have failed to catch the
vial as it dropped honestly that seems
to be a pretty realistic variance there
that catch was insanely lucky and
perfectly timed then there's option d
rumlow could have kept the payload
himself and instead of detonating
himself as a suicide bomb he could abuse
that vial to infect himself and infect
cap and then wanda maximoff an attempt
to contain this does what she did with
the explosion tosses the whole infection
into a nearby crowded building leading
to a super spreader disaster and a
zombie outbreak now option e could be if
the avengers thought they secured the
payload but then it just got released
sometime later either through shady
government corruption or someone else in
the future stealing it like zemo in any
of these cases the world would debate
over who was responsible for the
outbreak and thaddeus ross might instead
approach bucky barnes for a mission to
hunt down patient zero zombie cap his
old friend as they seek a possible cure
to this disease now looking at trailer
footage it's also possible that this
episode is partially set later in the
mcu timeline maybe something that lasts
years because that one shot of zombie
tony stark also shows zombie ebony maw
in zombie call obsidian remember first
come to earth in infinity war in 2018.
also the shot of bucky we see shows him
with that new vibranium arm the one the
wakandans gave him upon thanos arrival
to replace the hydra arm that iron man
blasted off back in civil war so that
would mean the zombie outbreak could be
raging across the world as bucky is
safely quarantined in wakanda which
might be a kind of safe zone cut off
from the rest of the world during this
outbreak and i think ebony ma call
obsidian perhaps even thanos could be
the extraterrestrial invaders to replace
galactus from the kirkman comics these
guys get infected upon their arrival to
earth now the other interesting trailer
shot shows janet van dyne apparently
zombified in the quantum realm
suggesting to some of us that janet
could have brought this in with her from
the quantum realm but i'm not so sure
now because we hardly saw janet's
quantum realm backstory to begin with
for this series to show how it changed
so instead i think this could be the
final shot of the episode with janet
getting infected down in the quantum
realm and going through a time vortex
jumping back maybe jumping forward
either way creating new branch timelines
all infected with this zombie virus as
more and more of the multiverse falls
victim to this outbreak let me know your
theories about this upcoming episode i'm
so excited for it again you can support
new rockstars by checking out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow and subscribe to the rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you